hello and welcome to this video GM
Edmundo was probably how I should should
read this yeah this is the featured game
132 spectators 33 now okay so is going
with the b5 I really have no clue I'm
currently trying all kinds of stuff in
the deform the d4 universe testing out
things for my keep it simple a d4 rabbit
GM at mundo is a blitz specialist only
playing blitz
I still have a ton of bullet games in
there even though 3,000 bullet games
this is really sick um yeah I stopped
playing any bullet roughly a year ago
I only do it very occasionally in been
to blitz sessions on chest 24 and
there's just like a minute left and then
how they okay let's go let's go for a
bullet game to just exactly as I kill
the time in basic them anyway
GM Edmundo we are here I think this is
probably equal ish position even though
the move b5 it's slightly sticking out
for black so I maybe can maybe I can
know what that is surprising why would
you voluntarily play this move okay
see I mean it's not like I don't think
it is so terrible or anything it just
I'm surprised I wouldn't it wouldn't
come to my mind to play d5
you
I don't have control over them over the
c5 square and the desert is very
important
I can call Knight e5 in this position
but
okay yeah I'm going to route this
towards c5
but he's got Luke ch yeah exactly
and this is some
this is fine probably like
you
you
you
I'm looking for potential technical
tricks but there is not
and see anything
you
more difficult
yes before is going to be formed
okay I can really want annoyed towards
before and try to make and it looks very
strange right him
like very strange event
tonight a one
you know my usual rule is if a move
looks completely stupid that it is
stupid it will see
they actually managed to put a night
like
see two nights before I could try to at
least try to claim that the bishop is so
not great down but he has this that's
true
see for a night before night see form
you know
yes tone it's it's this is kind of what
was happening and was clear that this
would happen after my of my maneuver so
the queenside is rather blocked now the
the issue is can can I do something on
the other side of the board let's let's
see
might be maybe I can
doll
he covered he covered six just for good
measure let's aim
you
it's very very difficult to measure
to do something really
maybe some some g4 let's see five was
possible but not leading to anything
if
for luck I have it on
I then would be quite a week he's still
doing it
you
No
f was thing I cannot calculate it you
have to have to go for it b2 is hanging
but
I can take with the night actually that
is silly I did not I told I totally
forgot that you can take with the night
I know 95
and play this like an idiot just like an
idiot where do I go to d3 of all old
squares
silly
distilling I mean he didn't quite refute
it but
is not
just barely played 17 seconds
[Music]
yeah that is not that wasn't good for
him but
still might be playable from like
oh yeah maybe not this is not play or
public
I had the rukon the third and maybe it
was good for me
yeah the last couple of horses didn't
help like
you
we're setting the clock run out okay no
no that wasn't me that was a bad game
really and so yeah we had this kind of
thing which is probably just about equal
it's not much I was surprised by d5
anyway so now we had this regrouping
night Aoife affair there's something
there thought about but I was unsure
this was my idea but this all 94 maybe
this is a better choice the the way I
played it is probably too passive
I think this looks too passive relief
a form yeah before that is also
something that I felt could be could
could be played
for Bishop a six
the engine recommends this but I don't
think I would have played that this
looks a weaker shank yeah it's not very
good
yeah I played this just not well now we
had this weird good well good way of
playing
you know but I managed to I know I don't
huh you should you should do that and
then play me for
yeah that is that is that is probably a
good a good way to play can take this
this is better for black quite quite
nicely better as my bishop is not
helping at all
okay the engines has queen a3 is sort of
defense but that is very unattractive
okay he played this after which I have
got this blockade and this is the
position where I think it's very
difficult to do something I actually
think that I mean we kind of shuffled
back and forth in a way I think that if
I'm is risky yeah but he he went for it
take bishop takes and now I didn't play
it right here this Knight f4 is just
totally stupid I I absolutely over
looked at p2 hangs with an idea Bishop
takes I was well off but he can take but
the night and I should probably just do
something lame man King g1 the non move
and say okay you don't have anything
either and this is just bad Jam 995 now
it's just strong it's basically end of
game
you know I mean the threat is to take
and play deform that's just over they
have to deform it still kind of
continued
in Bishop age forms also odd night a 3m
that is also killing air was very lucky
it was very lucky winner three now would
win okay mayor that makes sense I take
this and indirectly attack this it's now
a for has come okay I just I just saw
that I have this book g3 idea now and
now it seems the only move to not
immediately losing sking f8 and this is
stuff
you know King f8 and then after this get
the Queen's of the board he is
struggling up like a support down but
it's probably it's the only way
rookie 7 and this is winning Queen g3
years are killing and killing moving us
okay Brooke e6 still hangs on him
yeah it's still it's still not very
comfortable so to say the least
okay guys thanks for watching